now the entire multiverse is about to
come under attack
there is a malevolent force at work one
driven by a singular goal I hope your
watching big guy!
welcome back everyone press f in the
chat for everyone in the air overs for
all those people that are gone, this will be
my crisis on Infinite Earths episode 1
video there was a whole bunch of Easter
eggs a bunch of cameos so we'll break it
all down if you're new to the channel
I'll be doing videos for all the
episodes of the crossover be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're doing
a flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the episode on
the video careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
because so much stuff happen but we'll
do top 10 and easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10 the
monitor explains the origin of the
multiverse it kind of starts with a
universe Big Bang explainer and then how
everything split out into different
universes till we get to the modern-day
multiverse he has not fully explained
the origin of the anti-monitor yet but
we just got a teaser for that at the end
of the episode with pariah Welles the
newly minted pariah Welles formerly Nash
wells so they'll probably explain that
in episode 2 which will be tomorrow
night on Monday but number 9 all the
cameos from the actors from other DC
movies and television shows so we start
with earth 89 for the Batman 1989 movie
they play the theme song from the Batman
1989 movie and then Robert wuhl who
played Alexander Knox during that movie
cameos reading a newspaper from the
Gotham Gazette which was the newspaper
he worked for reading Batman captures
Joker headline and in the picture it's
actually Michael Keaton's version of
Batman but here's the thing when the
skies turned red and he gets really
upset and turns to look at the sky at
the back signal and says I hope you're
out there watching big guy it's not
Michael Keaton's Batman symbol it's a
different one that looks more like the
bat woman bat symbol which is kind of
weird I don't know why they did it that
way if they're going for the Batman 1989
reference why wouldn't you just use his
Batman logo but that might have been a
licensing thing maybe Warner Brothers
didn't let them use that but the weird
thing is is that he's got the correct
logo in the newspaper article if you
zoom in and look on his chest
it's Michael Keaton's classic Batman
logo so I don't know why this would be
different from the bat signal in the sky
then we go to earth 9 and it winds up
being the Titans cameo with Jason Todd
and hog the funny thing about this is if
you watch the Titans finale from season
2 Jason Todd is nowhere to be found so
apparently he was busy filming this
crossover when they were filming their
finale but you could say that this kind
of soft canon eise's Titans to the more
verse of the arrow verse but obviously
they're on a very different earth so
that explains why they're not running
into each other every single week we go
back to earth X from the cross over from
a couple years ago and the ray comes
back everybody wondered when he was
going to come back we go to earth 66 Gotham City for the bat me in 1966 TV series
Burt Ward in real life doing a very
Robin esque line of dialogue and walking
a dog that looks a lot like ace the
bat-hound from the Batman comics we then
go to Wil Wheaton who's on supergirls
earth earth 38 foretelling the doom of
all screaming at everyone about the end
of the world and if you're wondering why
Wil Wheaton had a cameo during this is
because he used to voice some animated
characters in the early 2000s in the DC
Universe so he has played DC characters
before the number 8 the redo on the
Superman origin scene so obviously we
meet baby John Kent Superboy this is
right out of the comics he's going to be on
that TV show that Superman's getting on
the CW next year I don't know if he's
still going to be a baby on that TV show
but they basically do Superman's origin
story because Argo city is going to get
wiped by the antimatter wave so they
stick him in the only pod that's left
and fire him off of that planet just
like supergirls origin story - the pod
goes off course and gets stuck in a
temporal wormhole and winds up on old
Oliver Queen from 2046 his planet which
is earth 16 so they can go back and
visit him from that cameo during legends
of tomorrow season 1 the one-armed older
version of Oliver Queen Superman also
confirmed later that Cara's mother
played by Erica Durance was also killed
but during episode 2 Erica Durance will
be back cameo II again as Lois Lane from
Smallville with Tom Welling Superman so
she will be back on the show this is big
thread with Oliver and Mia through the
episode because obviously she's going to
get the spin-off TV show that's going to
debut next year Green Arrow in the
Canaries I believe is the title of that
show all of his conversations with her
is basically him passing the torch
there's a lot of on-the-nose dialogue it
gets a little cringy and you kind of
tell what they're doing like oh there
should always be a green arrow because
you're getting a spin-off TV show the
reason why they had to rush that is
obviously because of the twist at the
end of the episode press F in the chat
for Oliver Queen because he wasn't going to
be around to pass the torch in episode 2
but the number 7 Harbinger goes around
collecting all the mains from the
different shows brings them to super
girls or
this sort of gives them the business
about what's going on with the
antimatter wave it's an event that
started a long time ago and has just
taken this long to get to their version
of Earth there was one more funny cameo
that I spotted during the legends of
tomorrow seen when harbingers showed up at the sports bar during quiz night to
pick them up the person leading quiz
night is actually Griffin Newman who you
might recognize as Arthur from Amazon's
the tick TV show but they're not trying
to canonize the tick to the arrow verse
or anything like that he was just being
a guest star in that funny role it's
just a funny coincidence that he was
also on the take TV show they have a
couple funny moments when all the heroes
show up but number six once Barry tells
Oliver about the future newspaper I'm
supposed to go, the monitor told me that
I have to Oliver gets all pissed off
cause a flag on the play and talks to
the monitor and he gives in the business
but the monitor tells him that the deal
he made to sacrifice his life in
exchange for Barry and Cara's only
covered last year's crossover during
Elseworlds all bets are off for a crisis
on Infinite Earths the reason why they
did that I think is for the writers to
keep the tension up otherwise you
wouldn't worry about the flash at all
but really to be honest most of the
mains will have to go back to their TV
shows after crisis not including Oliver
Queen press F in the chat one more time
but there were a couple moments at the
end of the episode especially lines of
dialogue from pariah Welles where they
said things aren't going down the way we
thought they would things are going to be
very different
that's the writers way to say that we're
changing things from the comics so that
they won't be quite so predictable and
you won't know what's happening three
episodes before it actually happens but
there are a couple things that you can
probably assume based on what's going on
with the shows going forward the flash
will come back there'll be a back half
of the season Supergirl will still have
a back half of the season most of the
legends will come back after the
crossover because their next season
starts right after crisis ends but they
just want you to think that it's still
possible for the flash to die during
this at some point if he does go though
he will have to be brought back to life
in some twisty way all explained the
twist with Oliver Queen though because
he's not out of the crossover completely
he will come back later in the crossover
but in a slightly different way but
number five another Oliver Queen old
Oliver Queen from 2046 they sort of give
him some closure when Sara Louis and
Brainiac go to earth 16 in the arrow
cave to pick up Jon Kent so not only is
this on a different earth it's another
earth
in the future the reason why they went
to this earth was to give him some
closure because he's like the sad old
version of Oliver Queen I'm so sad
everything's terrible all my friends are
dead everything's in ruins they wanted
to give him a happy moment and let him
be a little bit cheerful feel better
about the choices that he made like oh
wow it really worked out for me in an
alternate reality before the antimatter
wave comes and wipes his version of
Earth and they poured away it was also
an else world story where a version of
Superman
after his pod left Krypton actually
landed in Gotham City and he was adopted
by the Wayne's raised as their son and
got a very Batman esque version of a
Superman origin story so you could look
at this as a small Easter egg for that
kind of story because you have to assume
that if they had never shown up to pick
up baby John Kent then old Oliver Queen
would have raised him as his own son but
number four the battle to save the
planet you see all the ante monitors
minions they're supposed to be shadow
demons that's the way they were
described in Nora's future newspaper I
feel like the design of them is okay but
they're just meant to be like these big
CG creatures that they can blow up on a
whim the Jumpgate that they create to
get all the people off the planet looks
remarkably like a Stargate for anybody
who's fans of the Stargate TV series but
they're also doing the towers from the
comic book so in the comic book the
monitor creates these giant towers to
stop the anti-monitor they look like
they're ripped right off the comic book
page but the funny thing is is that
Harbinger says that the monitor placed
them there at the dawn of time on all
these different planets you would think
that the Legion of super-heroes with
their 30th century technology would be
able to detect something like that
underground the city Oliver has a couple
special arrows including three the new
trick one that he uses to disable the
monitor I'm assuming that that's the one
that he was using Curtis and all the
other people to collect stuff to create
but they kind of answered the question
with the monitor being evil with the
pariah well sort of tag at the end it's
not the monitor you need to be worried
about he definitely wants to help people
it's the anti-monitor that you need to
worry about when they come back to the
arrow cave the monitor is very clear
though that billions and billions of
people died but Oliver was able to save
an extra billion people by sacrificing
himself but then number two Nash wells
shows up as the pariah character from
the comics there's all this backstory
that he brushes over really quickly
explaining how he used to be Nash wells
and a lot of that gets into the prequel
scene that I did a video for a couple
days ago
they tagged it at the end of all the
episodes in the midseason finales the
same scene of Nashville's trying to
enter the monitors place the newly
minted pariah explains that he's now
serving his penance because what he was
actually doing there was being tricked
by the anti-monitor into releasing him
from his confinement so it did confirm
my theory that when he was speaking to
this person booming voice that he bowed
down and worshiped him and he'll get
everything that he wants he was actually
speaking to the anti-monitor who just
sounds a lot like the regular monitor
I'm assuming they'll show us a version
of that backstory during episode 2 maybe
just a quick couple scenes because we've
already seen all that stuff happened
where he opens the door and is bathed in
white light but those seven symbols were
the symbols of the seven different
Paragons they'll get into all that stuff
during episode two but episode 2 will
also be there Kevin Conroy Batman cameo
it'll also be Tom Welling's cameo and
that's what meet Kingdom come Superman
for the first time also played by
Brandon Routh really the biggest
surprise of the episode though was as
they let off with number one the death
of Oliver Queen press F in the chat
pulling out do whatever you want to say
your goodbyes but you won't be gone for
that long this version of Oliver Queen
definitely died here but Stephen Amell
will be back in the crossover later as a
slightly different version of the
character there's a lot of theories that
he will become the next version of The
Spectre in the arrowverse they've
already cast Jim Corrigan who is the
comic book spectre for the crossover
it's a different actor so what might
happen is is that he gets destroyed by the
anti-monitor so the god of the arrow
verse multiverse needs to select and
mint a new Spectre to replace him and
that person becomes Oliver Queen
but it's still open to speculation
so post all your theories in the
comments do you think that Oliver Queen
will come back later in the crossover as
a slightly different version of the
character of course I'll do a video for
episode 2 episode 3 those opposed Monday and Tuesday night I'll try to get to all
the videos as quickly as I can my next
video tomorrow morning will be for the
new Rick and Morty episode 4 and because
of so much stuff happening I won't be
able to get to Watchmen episode 7 but
the Watchmen finale is next week so
don't worry about that everyone click
here to watch the Wonder Woman 1984
trailer at all my easter eggs a billion
more times then click here for that
prequel scene of Nashville's becoming
Raya Wells thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!